Proteccionismo made in America
¿Por qué Estados Unidos pasa de los acuerdos
de libre comercio?
La nueva apuesta comercial de Biden
------
Con un producto interior bruto de cerca de
24 billones de dólares, Estados Unidos es
de lejos la economía más importante de todo
el mundo.
La economía norteamericana es tan grande
que por sí mismo supone casi una cuarta parte
de todo el PIB mundial.
Los norteamericanos devoran más productos
que nadie y prácticamente todos quieren comerciar
con ellos. Es con mucha diferencia el mercado
más importante y lucrativo del mundo. Ningún
otro país se acerca a la capacidad económica
de esta superpotencia.
Ahora bien, ¿Cómo de abierto está realmente
el tío Sam al comercio mundial? ¿Qué papel
juega el sistema de comercio mundial? ¿Conoces
la última apuesta de la Administración Biden
para integrar la economía norteamericana
con gran parte de América Latina?
Pues, queridos, amigos, amigas, en este vídeo
responder a ver todas estas cuestiones, pero
antes tenemos que saber exactamente de que
va toda esta historia.
Arranquemos.
Los seres humanos llevamos milenios comerciando,
por no decir que lo hemos hecho durante toda
nuestra historia.
Sin embargo, la idea de un mundo integrado
por redes comerciales y cadenas de producción
internacionales repartidas por aquí y por
allá es algo muchísimo más reciente. Algo
que a gran escala lleva con nosotros apenas
unas cuantas décadas.
Por ejemplo, los primeros acuerdos de libre
comercio entre países datan de 1860. Tuvieron
como protagonista, como no, al Imperio Británico,
con la firma del Tratado de Cobden-Chevalier
con Francia en enero de ese mismo año.
Décadas después, el Tratado de Versalles
de 1919 fue uno de los primeros documentos
multilaterales que consideró el intercambio
comercial entre países, como un eje clave
para la prosperidad global.
Sin embargo, la Segunda Guerra Mundial y la
Guerra Fría marcarían las décadas siguientes.
Por ejemplo, en su enfrentamiento con la Unión
Soviética, Estados Unidos promovió el libre
comercio, pero al mismo también mantuvo muchas
medidas proteccionistas sobre sectores considerados
estratégicos y a escala internacional se
centró sobre todo en cuestiones de seguridad.
De esta forma, la gran explosión del comercial
mundial no llegaría hasta los años 90 y
principios del s. XXI. Un proceso que, sorprendentemente,
no fue liderado claramente por Estados Unidos.
Atentos.
(T1: DEL AISLACIONISMO A LA RIVALIDAD CON
MOSCÚ)
Queridos amigos, existe un amplio consenso
acerca de Estados Unidos:
Una buena parte de su enorme éxito a la hora
explotar su inmenso potencial económico y
político tuvo lugar gracias a su particular
situación geopolítica.
¿Y sabéis qué? Esta es una interpretación
que viene de lejos. Fijaos:
C1 (No encontrando Estados Unidos en el exterior
enemigo alguno que pueda amenazarlo seriamente,
el pueblo americano está siempre ocupado
en la tarea de mejorar su situación”
Alexis de Tocqueville - La Democracia en América
(1835-1840))
C2 ("La peculiar seguridad de la geografía
americana dio a Estados Unidos una seguridad
económica que le permitió concentrarse en
las artes de la paz mientras dejaba a otras
naciones satisfacer su gusto por la guerra".
David Potter - People of Plenty: Economic
Abundance and the American Character (1954))
La realidad es que el Tío Sam creció en
un clima libre de grandes conflictos bélicos.
Y sí, lo sé, obviamente la guerra civil
y algunos roces militares relativamente menores,
como la Guerra con México, eventualmente
le hicieron agitar sus armas.
Pero, evidentemente, no es algo comparable
a los constantes conflictos que durante siglos
inundaron la historia de la vieja Europa.
Además, Estados Unidos tampoco sufrió nunca
las consecuencias de tener al mando a grandes
sátrapas más preocupados por extraer rentas
que por el desempeño económico del país
y la prosperidad general.
Y, ¿Qué queréis que os diga? Eso se nota.
En cualquier caso, la cuestión es que durante
años y años los estadounidenses hicieron
crecer su economía y desarrollaron un enorme
y próspero mercado interno, que, sin embargo,
se mantuvo en cierta forma alejado del resto
del mundo… Hasta que de una forma u otra
el mundo llegó hasta ellos.
Es lo que habitualmente se conoce como el
aislacionismo norteamericano.
Pero, ¿Queréis un ejemplo concreto de lo
que suponía esta vocación política y económica?
Pues fijaos, Estados Unidos evitó a toda
costa unirse a la Sociedad de Naciones, la
precursora de la ONU, a pesar de que su propio
presidente, Woodrow Wilson, había sido uno
de sus grandes promotores. Por aquella época
Estados Unidos no estaba particularmente interesado
en el resto del mundo.
Eh, incluso, recordad todo lo que les costó
meterse de lleno en la Segunda Guerra Mundial.
Pero, claro, justo fue en esa época cuando
se produjo un punto de inflexión que cambiaría
la historia del mundo.
Cuando las fuerzas japonesas bombardearon
Pearl Harbor, de repente cambiaron la perspectiva
norteamericana para siempre. A partir de ese
momento el país de las barras y las estrellas
nunca jamás volvería a mirar para otro lado.
Pero… Vale, vale, lo sé, ¿qué demonios
tiene todo esto que ver con el tema de este
vídeo?
Pues veréis, la cuestión es que en 1941
en la conocida Carta del Atlántico, acordada
tras una reunión secreta entre Churchill
y Roosevelt, estos dos países se fijaron
esta meta:
C3 (Cláusula 4. [...] Extender a todos los
Estados, pequeños o grandes, victoriosos
o vencidos, la posibilidad de acceso a condiciones
de igualdad, al comercio y a las materias
primas mundiales que son necesarias para su
prosperidad económica.
Carta del Atlántico - 14 de agosto de 1941)
De esta forma, cuando terminó la guerra y
se levantó el telón de acero, Washington
cayó en un período de “pactomania”.
Es decir, para entendernos, en una especie
de obsesión casi compulsiva por alcanzar
nuevos acuerdos con otros países.
Hablamos de la época del Plan Marshall o
la creación de la propia OTAN.
C4 (“Es lógico que Estados Unidos haga
todo lo que esté a su alcance para contribuir
al retorno de la salud económica normal en
el mundo, sin la cual no puede haber estabilidad
política ni paz segura (...) Los gobiernos,
partidos políticos o grupos que busquen perpetuar
la miseria humana con el fin de beneficiarse
políticamente o de otra manera, encontrarán
la oposición de los Estados Unidos”. Discurso
del Secretario de Estado, George Marshall
el 5 de junio de 1947)
La prioridad entonces era absolutamente clara:
todas las herramientas de cooperación económica
formaban parte de los instrumentos que Estados
Unidos podía emplear en su particular cruzada
contra la Unión Soviética.
Y este era quizás el único “problema”:
digamos, la obsesión norteamericana se centraba
en alcanzar acuerdos que le dieran ventaja
geopolítica frente a Moscú y la amenaza
soviética. Es decir, el comercio era por
así decirlo un instrumento de lucha… No
tan un fin por sí mismo.
Pero, aun así, se lograron avances muy importantes.
Bajos aranceles, reglas comunes, plena movilidad
de las mercancías y casi total libertad de
cambio.
Y, claro, ya os podéis hacer una idea, si
estas son cosas difíciles de concretar hoy
en día, imaginaos en los años 50, cuándo
además todavía reinaba una enorme desconfianza
hacía el recién creado orden internacional
bipolar.
Así que sí, el GATT se aprobó, pero no
logró forzar a las potencias occidentales
a reducir sus aranceles, sino que esto se
dejó a discreción de los diferentes gobiernos.
Además, poco después 1948 tuvo lugar la
Conferencia de las Naciones Unidas sobre Comercio
y Empleo en La Habana, y el 24 de marzo de
ese mismo año, 53 estados occidentales firmaron
una carta procurando la creación de la conocida
Organización Internacional del Comercio.
Sin embargo, queridos amigos, justo aquí
reapareció con fuerza el fantasma del aislacionismo
estadounidense:
En el año 1950, el presidente Truman anunció
que no presentaría la “Carta de La Habana”,
ya que en el Senado, la mayoría de los legisladores
se oponían a formar parte de esta organización.
Por supuesto, en aquel momento, si Estados
Unidos se quedaba fuera, eso significaba que
la propuesta automáticamente quedaba cancelada.
De esa forma, el prematuro sueño de tener
una organización comercial internacional
llegó a su fin. Las negociaciones y la promoción
del comercio internacional se llevaría a
cabo en diferentes rondas del GATT.
El problema es que fue un gran acuerdo con
muchas limitaciones.
El tratado tenía poco poder para hacer cumplir
las normas;
estaba muy limitado a la hora de resolver
las diferentes disputas y solo alcanzaba al
mercado de bienes. No a los servicios ni a
la propiedad intelectual ni tampoco a la inversión
extranjera.
Digamos que era una especie de acuerdo de
mínimos… que luego a la hora de la verdad
muchos países no respetaban. Además, a medida
que más países se incorporaron a este acuerdo,
las diferentes negociaciones se volvieron
interminables.
Sin embargo, a medida que la Guerra Fría
empezó a descongelarse, las viejas ideas
de la integración volvieron a ganar peso
en Estados Unidos… Y con ello, en todo occidente.
La caída del muro supuso todo un punto de
inflexión, un antes y un después.
(T2: CAÍDA DEL MURO Y UNIPOLARIDAD ECONÓMICA)
Entre 1947 y 1990, tuvieron lugar cerca de
8 rondas de negociaciones enmarcadas en el
acuerdo GATT. En ellas los Estados partes
se reunían para acordar nuevas medidas para
facilitar el comercio exterior
El problema es que estas negociaciones eran
larguísimas: en promedio, cada ronda duraba
29 meses… Sí, sí, me has escuchado y no
nos hemos equivocado. De media, cada vez que
se quería reducir alguna barrera comercial
se tiraban negociando más de 2 años.
Eso sí, pese a todo avances, lo que se dice
avances, sí que se lograron. Por ejemplo,
la ronda iniciada en Suiza en mayo de 1964,
conocida como la “Ronda Kennedy” supuso
un importante salto adelante:
Se redujeron a la mitad los aranceles de muchas
materias primas.
Y se eliminaron un montón de barreras no
arancelarias.
(Aquí el presidente John F. Kennedy jugó
un papel clave. En 1962 logró que el Congreso
le diera poderes extraordinarios en materia
de política comercial. Fue la conocida como
Ley de Expansión Comercial.
El presidente justificó que Estados Unidos
tenía que moverse rápido porque tenía la
imperiosa necesidad de estrechar más lazos
y conseguir más aliados, especialmente en
los países en vías de desarrollo. Y sobre
todo en América Latina. ¿Por qué? Pues
porque en esos países la Unión Soviética
estaba siendo muy activa. En terminología
de la época, había que contrarrestar el
avance rojo.)
El caso es que esa ley le permitió al gobierno
de Estados Unidos tener un papel muy activo
en aquella ronda de Suiza, aún cuándo el
presidente formaba ya parte de los libros
de historia.
Claro que, las siguientes rondas serían bastante
distintas, mucho más pantanosas, con avances
más o menos constantes pero a frecuentemente
excesivamente tímidos.
Esto fue así hasta que en septiembre de 1986
comenzó la 8.ª ronda en Uruguay.
Esta duraría nada más y nada menos que 87
meses. Más de 7 años en los que se produjeron
hechos clave: la caída del Muro de Berlín
y la disolución de la Unión Soviética.
Cuando empezó la ronda en Uruguay, Ronald
Reagan estaba en la Casa Blanca, pero tras
meses y meses de negociaciones en Montevideo,
Ginebra , Bruselas , Washington, DC y Tokio,
el gobierno norteamericano cambió 2 veces
de mano: primero a Bush (padre) y luego a
Bill Clinton.
Eso sí, en 1993, por fin, de una vez por
todas las naciones participantes alcanzaron
un acuerdo. Y no hablamos de un acuerdo cualquiera.
Con el fin de la Guerra Fría había surgido
un mundo nuevo, un mundo que necesitaba un
nuevo sistema de cooperación comercial.
Y, así, queridos amigos, fue como resurgió
con éxito la idea de contar con una organización
multilateral, un organismo para gobernar el
comercio mundial.
Atentos.
(T3: CLINTON, LA OMC Y LA INTEGRACIÓN…
QUE NO FUE)
El día 15 de abril de 1994, fue un día histórico
para la economía mundial. Ese día 123 países,
incluyendo los EE. UU., firmaron el Acuerdo
de Marrakech, que estableció la creación
de la Organización Mundial del Comercio (OMC).
Y queridos amigos y amigas, este fue, de lejos,
el despegue definitivo de la integración
económica mundial. El salto definitivo de
la globalización y la construcción del mundo
que hoy conocemos. Tal y como podéis ver
a partir de ese momento los acuerdos comerciales
se multiplicaron.
Ante semejante escenario, la presidencia de
Bill Clinton apostó por ir a fondo con esta
nueva organización, consiguiendo algunos
hitos tan importantes como la entrada de la
mismísima República Popular China a este
organismo. Sin embargo, he aquí lo más curioso
de todo, los esfuerzos de Washington se centraron
particularmente en el resto del mundo.
Es decir, en Casa Blanca aún no había ninguna
catarata de nuevos traslados de libre comercio
que el país tuviese pensado firmar con un
mundo que estaba abandonando el socialismo
a toda velocidad para echarse en brazos del
comercio, el capitalismo y la globalización.
Pensad que, por aquel entonces, el único
tratado relevante en materia de libre comercio
que mantenía Estados Unidos era un acuerdo
en 1988 con Canadá. Un acuerdo que en 1994
Clinton convertiría con la inclusión de
México en el Tratado de Libre Comercio de
América del Norte, el archiconocido NAFTA.
Este fue el primer gran paso que Estados Unidos
dio para sumarse a la nueva ola en favor del
comercio libre que se extendía por todo el
mundo.
(Me gustaría dar la bienvenida a los representantes
de México y Canadá, y decirles que, de verdad,
son bienvenidos aquí. Son nuestros socios
en ese futuro que intentamos construir juntos.).
Claro que el entusiasmo norteamericano tardaría
todavía en dar resultados. No fue hasta el
año 2004 cuándo Estados Unidos suscribió
nuevos acuerdos de libre comercio con Chile,
Australia, Jordania, Singapur, República
Dominicana y Centroamérica.
El entonces presidente George W. Bush era
un firme partidario de extender y ampliar
está política. Sin embargo, en 2005 se produjo
un portazo terriblemente doloroso que dejaría
muchas secuelas en la Casa Blanca.
¿Qué de qué estamos hablando? Pues… Atentos.
(T4: UNA SUPERPOTENCIA RECHAZADA POR SUS VECINOS)
En noviembre de 2003, 34 países - prácticamente
todo el continente americano al complejo - se
reunieron en Miami para conocer un plan ideado
por la Casa Blanca, un plan sin precedentes
que buscaba extender el Tratado de Libre Comercio
de América del Norte entre Canadá, México
y los Estados Unidos a toda la región, creando
así la conocida como Área de Libre Comercio
de las Américas (ALCA).
El acuerdo tenía que cerrarse en un plazo
de dos años, pero justo para 2005, en la
IV Cumbre de las Américas realizada en Argentina,
George W. Bush se dio de frente con la ola
roja que por aquel momento - al igual que
ocurre en nuestros días, y casi que da igual
cuando veas este vídeo -atravesaba la región:
(Aquí en Mar del Plata está la tumba del
alca. Alca, alca, al carajo. Hugo Chávez,
presidente de Venezuela 1999-2013)
(Nuestros pobres, nuestros excluidos, nuestros
países, nuestra democracia ya no soportan
más que sigamos hablando en voz baja, es
fundamental hablar con mucho
respeto y en voz alta para construir un sistema
que nos vuelva a contener a todos en un marco
de igualdad y nos vuelva a devolver la esperanza
y la posibilidad de construir obviamente un
mundo distinto. Nestor Kirchner, Presidente
de Argentina, 2003-2007)
En 2005, se cumplían 55 años desde que el
Congreso estadounidense rechazara el proyecto
para crear la Organización Internacional
del Comercio. Pasadas casi 5 décadas, el
gobierno federal por fin había logrado liderar
una postura contra al aislacionismo:
Ni más ni menos que impulsar una zona económica
común con, literalmente, todos sus vecinos.
El ALCA no fue una demanda de América Latina,
fue una oferta de Washington que increíblemente
fue rechazada, lo que supuso una de las jornadas
más humillantes para la política exterior
de Estados Unidos de las últimas décadas.
La idea, el plan, la gran apuesta del despacho
oval había sido maltratada pública y notoriamente
por los grandes referentes socialistas de
aquella época.
Al finalizar aquella Cumbre, Bush se fue de
Argentina dando por finalizada la aventura
de integración. Irónicamente, está vez
era el mundo -en este caso Latinoamérica-
el que le decía, no a EE. UU… Lo que, por
supuesto, supuso rechazar una oportunidad
de oro para integrar Latinoamérica con la
mayor economía de todo el planeta. Ver para
creer.
(“¿Por qué no quieren tener acceso al
mercado de Estados Unidos? Los acuerdos comerciales
reducen los aranceles y las barreras. Eso
es lo que hacen. Por eso tenemos acuerdos
de libre comercio. No lo hacen más difícil,
sino que facilitan el acceso al mercado. ¿Y
por qué alguien no querría acceder a nuestro
mejor mercado? No lo sé.)
Fue una apuesta fallida.. Qué supuso otro
punto de inflexión más para Estados Unidos.
Atentos.
(T5: POST ALCA: TODO MUCHO MÁS MEDIDO)
Estados Unidos había comenzado su gran apertura
comercial con sus vecinos más próximos,
México y Canadá. Luego quiso llevar esta
apuesta a todo el continente americano, pero
el portazo al ALCA hizo que Washington se
cansara muy pronto.
Actualm ente, estos son tan solo los 19 tratados
de libre comercios de Estados Unidos en vigor.
Y eso no es todo. Si además de los acuerdos
de libre comercio consideramos otros acuerdos
menos, podemos comprobar como la apertura
del gigante norteamericano… Es mucho más
limitada.
Pero… ¿Cómo demonios es posible que países
como Perú, Turquía, China o, incluso, Ucrania
hayan suscrito más acuerdos comerciales que
los mismísimos Estados Unidos?
¿Realmente es Estados Unidos un país tan
cerrado? Pues… Lo cierto es que aquí hay
que hacer varios matices. Empezando por este:.
C5 (“Los Estados Unidos siguen llevando
a cabo la mayor parte de sus intercambios
comerciales en régimen de cláusula de nación
más favorecida (NFM en inglés), si bien
ofrecen desde hace mucho tiempo preferencias
unilaterales a los países en desarrollo y
los países menos adelantados”. Examen de
políticas comerciales de la OMC (2022))
(Estados Unidos sigue realizando la mayor
parte de sus intercambios comerciales bajo
la cláusula de la Nación más Favorecida.
Una cláusula de la OMC que garantiza que
el mejor trato que un país miembro le da
a otro miembro tiene que aplicarse a todos.
Excepto en los casos de acuerdos de libre
comercio.
De esta forma, Estados Unidos fija sus aranceles
y luego los aplica de forma general. Esto
hace que, por ejemplo, en 2021 el 49,9% de
todas las importaciones de los Estados Unidos
ingresaran libres de aranceles. El 14,8% de
las importaciones se beneficiaron de reducciones
arancelarias y el 0,9% se benefició de preferencias
unilaterales en favor de los países más
pobres.)
En otras palabras, no es que Estados Unidos
se haya cerrado al mundo ni renunciando a
los beneficios del comercio, sino que más
bien ha utilizado hasta la saciedad la normativa
de la OMC en materia de aranceles.
Por ejemplo, negociando y estableciendo el
nivel de aranceles para cada tipo de producto.
Esto le ha dado a Washington un control mucho
más político en la gestión del comercio.
Y es lo que explica noticias como estas:
N1 (Junio 2022: La crisis millonaria de la
aceituna negra española por el arancel de
Estados Unidos. El Economista)
N2 (30 octubre 2021: La UE y EE. UU. desactivan
su guerra arancelaria sobre el acero y el
aluminio. El Pais)
Eso sí, todo hay que decirlo, con carácter
general, Estados Unidos aplica una tarifa
aduanera que está entre las más bajas del
mundo. Hablamos de un promedio del 3,5%.
Pero, sea como sea, en los últimos años
Estados Unidos hace no mucho que Washington
sí que estuvo trabajando en la posible creación
de una zona de libre comercio entre EE. UU.
y Oriente Medio, un acuerdo de Asociación
Transpacífico y una utópica Asociación
Transatlántica de Comercio e Inversión con
la Unión Europea. Sin embargo, la llegada
de Trump a la Casa Blanca hizo que todos estos
esfuerzos de la Administración Obama quedaran
en saco roto.
Claro que ahora esa posición podría volver
a cambiar, y podría hacerlo, además, en
América Latina. ¿Habéis oído hablar de
la última apuesta de la Administración Biden
en materia de comercio? ¿Estamos ante un
nuevo desembarco gringo en América Latina?
Pues… ¡Atentos!
(T6: ALIANZA PARA LA PROSPERIDAD ECONÓMICA
EN LAS AMÉRICAS: ¿ALCA 2.0?)
En junio del 2022 se anunció la creación
de la “Alianza para la Prosperidad Económica
en las Américas”: una iniciativa que tiene
como países miembros a Barbados, Canadá,
Chile, Colombia, Costa Rica, República Dominicana,
Ecuador, México, Panamá, Perú, Uruguay,
y que comienza a pintar como un ALCA más
moderado, pero encaminado a construir tarde
o temprano una nueva alianza estrecha y con
una fuerte apuesta comercial. Eso sí, entre
“amigos cercanos”:
C6 (“Este diálogo reúne la fuerza, el
ingenio y la diversidad de una región increíblemente
dinámica. Somos el 90 % del PIB del Hemisferio
Occidental. Casi dos tercios de su población.
No hay nada que no podamos hacer juntos.”
Anthony J. Blinken, Secretario de Estado de
Estados Unidos)
Todavía se conocen pocos detalles, pero por
el momento la Casa Blanca ha dejado claro
que esta iniciativa nace para impulsar el
comercio, la inversión y la aplicación de
normativas comunes entre los países que forman
parte de esta nueva iniciativa. Entre otras
cosas, es una de las fórmulas con las que
la Administración Biden aspira a reducir
el peso de China. ¿Cómo? Impulsando las
cadenas de producción regionales, el nearshoring
del que ya os hemos hablado aquí en VisualPolitik.
(La Alianza de las Américas acelerará nuestro
trabajo común para reforzar las cadenas de
suministro y hacerlas más resistentes a futuras
crisis, de modo que los bienes y productos
de los que dependen nuestras poblaciones sean
asequibles y estén disponibles, y que se
respeten los derechos de los trabajadores
al hacerlo. Antony Blinken, Secretario de
Estado de Estados Unidos)
En cualquier caso, si algo está claro es
que puede ser una oportunidad de oro, una
más, para que América Latina pueda de una
vez por todas dar un enorme salto hacia adelante.
¿Cómo? Pues si sus dirigentes son espabilados
aprovechándose del mayor mercado de consumo
e inversión de todo el planeta.
En cualquier caso, queridos amigos, no me
negaréis que tiene cierta gracia, que Estados
Unidos, la gran potencia capitalista que ganó
la Guerra Fría y que-no haya conseguido liderar
el sistema de comercio mundial.
Pero llegados hasta aquí, turno para ti:
¿Crees que Estados Unidos tendría que ser
mucho más ambicioso con su política comercial?
¿Sería algo bueno o malo? ¿Qué papel llegará
a jugar la ALIANZA PARA LA PROSPERIDAD ECONÓMICA
EN LAS AMÉRICAS? Déjanos tú impresiones
en los comentarios y abramos debate.
Si este vídeo os ha resultado interesante
no olvidéis darle a like y suscribiros a
VisualPolitik si es que aún no lo has hecho.
Un saludo y hasta la próxima.